i saw a lot of twitter and a lot of
organizations
news sites that were giving them for for
not for not wearing a mask
well i also saw the did you see the
article that said that
uh the tom brady fandom is is
one of the last expressions of like
white rage or whatever i
swear to god i was ready i saw the
headline i'm like you got to be kidding
me
are you serious oh yeah they're already
starting with the tom brady represents
white it's the best
it's just so hard to take these people
seriously yeah i saw
i did i did see
oh man there's a there's not one mic
there's a few oh no i thought yeah it's
starting
it's already starting tom brady is tom
brady
is obviously because he's a white man
who's successful that's literally the uh
the
only thing to like this is why i love
when they go after the tom brady's
and the chris pratt's and and and uh
those kind of guys i love when they go
after those kind of guys because
it really kind of reveals like
who they are inside because they it's
there's no reason to hate certain guys
because they haven't done anything and
you're like oh they're clearly a neon
and you're like what i don't well
they've never forgiven him for having a
maga hat in his locker room
they've never forgiven him okay but
that's it that is not for them to
forgive
no no i know i can only be with you the
balls on these [ __ ] people that just
go like
you know like dude these guys are
literally without controversy and they
have to find a way to to put the
label on them and it's like all that
dude does
like tom brady is basically like not
even a human being he's a
weirdo who only cares about football
hasn't eaten a car since 2000
counts every calorie eats probably has
never experienced joy in his life
you know what i mean he's just one of
those guys that's like when is the next
game
that's just like that's it like he
probably is told by his wife when
they're gonna [ __ ]
and it's like okay and he just goes he
shows up you know he
probably sticks to his schedule she's
just like four o'clock we're [ __ ] and
he's like okay
we'll be there three three seven he
probably calls her coach
you know like it's okay coach you know
what i mean like it's this whole thing
is just i want to play football leave me
alone and
he doesn't he doesn't bang kids he's not
drinking and driving
he's not stabbing people at [ __ ]
strip clubs all right he's white i know
that's that's what i mean and they hate
him you know they hate him and all he
does is play football and go the [ __ ]
home
that's all he does so
this somebody put a bunch of these
together i here we go
toxic masculinity is on full display oh
yeah this was not stop last night
check marks call out tom brady for not
wearing a mask of the super bowl
good good
uh it's about time we've addressed this
tampa bay star qb tom brady arrived the
super bowl without masking today
and people have have thoughts
so somebody retweeted is everyone in
this clip except tom brady wearing a
mask
of course uh considering everything
happening in the stadium i doubt this
actually matters but
a dude as famous as tom brady should be
do the right thing and wear a mask i
think i have to turn off this game it's
making me angry
imagine being a man and not watching the
super bowl
because tom brady didn't wear a mask
to be fair i mean these aren't men
yeah these aren't even people who
normally watch football it's the super
bowl
so it's we're not talking about like a
bar stool
sports guy saying that and you going
like what the [ __ ] is you know what i
mean
during a regular season game we're
talking about the super bowl where every
it's like
the super bowl is like the st patrick's
day of football right
it's the day where everybody drinks it's
the day where everybody watches even if
they're not like
you know what i mean like even if you're
not an alcoholic on st patrick's day
you're probably gonna get loaded yeah
yeah and it's like with the super bowl
you probably don't even watch football
but it's
it's super bowl you're gonna watch it so
this is where a lot of these kind of
you know types start popping up out of
the woodwork and they're like oh is
football an expression of whites
and you're like no next question go away
stop ruining football
jenna wadsworth says obviously not at
cdcgov she tagged the cdc
gov guidelines since tom brady at tom
brady's privilege
does she not realize that tom brady
outranks anybody at the cdc yeah
in american hierarchy yes of course he
does like
who's who from the seat they're gonna be
like oh i'm from the cdc and he's gonna
go it's clump tom brady
greatest of all time i mean we have an
issue
i've literally made john elway my [ __ ]
so
like what do you what do you do to point
that little mask
so tom brady's privileged toxic
masculinity's on full display without a
mask covering his
smug face well that part i'll give you
that part but it's not his fault this
face is small i'm just saying
yeah okay if we're going to attack them
for where they're wrong we have to give
them credit where they're right now the
smug face part i will give you
it's the white supremacy and then i also
love this privilege thing right like
it's it's sort of like how many people
go through life and they go
you know it's not fair like they'll see
some guy that go like you know what why
do i gotta go work at a factory and
these guys
are getting millions of dollars to chase
a ball around and you're like because
they're good at it because they
practiced they got really good at it
and because it is a very very elite like
whether you like football or sports or
not
it's very very hard even if you practice
and you're obsessed with sports right
and it's your entire life it's still
very hard to get to that level
and it's like to pretend like work
didn't go into it it's my favorite
they're just like
is he privileged like yeah yeah the
patriots made tom brady
uh a starting quarterback for a decade
because he's a good-looking white guy
do you really think that that's the
reason or is it just because he took it
he could take coach instructions and go
so get the ball over you got it and just
deliver when he's asked to deliver
that's not an easy job there's a reason
why there's so many mediocre
quarterbacks in the nfl
because it takes a lot to be the best uh
[ __ ]
privilege i love that max lewis these
are all verified people
brady is apparently too good to wear a
mask
uh of course uh tim brady tim brady
isn't wearing a mask go inflate some
balls
i mean at least get his name right yeah
and by the way that was a woman of
course i want to point out
yeah timothy yeah hey why don't you go
deflate some balls
tim brady like why are you just lady
where are you come on you know
get out in your wheelhouse right now and
then of course
uh uh nfl game day i had no interest
whatsoever in winning or losing i just
was injured in taking the next breath
at tom brady's parents sat down with
andrea kramer to detail tom brady senior
overcoming covet
and the excitement of getting to see his
son play in the 10th super
so they're trying to wow let's take that
let's take that a
wonderful heartwarming story let's [ __ ]
on that
let's just [ __ ] all over that right
let's let's call tom brady a super
spreading white
because he was there's a picture of him
kissing his dad's forehead and going
like hey
look at us uh my dad's alive i won the
super bowl yeah look at that and they're
going you [ __ ]
you're a piece of [ __ ] somebody posted a
picture of tom brady every single year
he play he played
i you know what they did this uh during
the during the game yep they did some
kind of like
morphing thing and you're like and you
really it sinks in you're like
this dude's been around forever forever
uh
somebody who actually put code covert
won't be around for that long and then
covet
it's just [ __ ] everything that's
hilarious
that's very funny i like that
my favorite tom brady big one is uh
okay two between two kind of little
chunky tom brady over here
or the jonathan taylor thomas tom brady
i actually lean with the jonathan taylor
thomas the part in the middle
yeah it's very late 90s it's very late
90s early 2000s yeah
that is a specifically early 2000s look
yeah it's the aj soprano haircut yeah
but like no he's not chunky in the other
one i think he's way more beefed up
i think you might be right i think he
was just because you know when you're a
quarterback they they'll tell you like
you can lose muscle you don't need to be
jacked to be and he was probably all
voided out in college
yeah you know what i mean he was
probably coming down off the road
because he was probably like [ __ ]
jacked in college and then they were
like look man
you don't need to be huge to be a
quarterback
uh the amount of people that are really
really that are mad i think it's
hilarious for the record ma holmes is
missing his whole starting o-line but
grady's
brady's still the does it matter stop i
understand you guys want mahomes to be
the best person in the world
i understand listen he's a great
quarterback but he's like 12 years old
get over he lost the super bowl
he made it to the super bowl didn't he
already win one listen
hasn't he already won a super bowl yeah
he's won so calm down
nobody's saying he's gonna win nobody's
saying patrick mahomes
is bad it just was he got carved up by
tom brady
last night he's gonna win more don't
worry about it okay
i honestly felt bad for him i was
watching that game and i was like
like i gotta give my homes props for
being he's a tough dude because that was
like
he was wobbling towards the end man but
he finished the whole game
but he he looked like somebody who
really didn't want to finish that game
because they were just pounding him and
it was just like he kept getting up like
okay i can go more i look like jesus
dude